bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end l
émission consacrée à vos loisirs et vos
idées de sorties alors il sera question
de musique avec le premier tremplin rock
organisé ce week end à voisins le
bretonneux nous parlerons également
d'opéra de cinéma mais tout d'abord
place à nos premiers premiers invités
pas
ce week end à saint cyr l'école la ferme
de gally accueille un drôle de spectacle
ce sera le dimanche 8 mars à partir de
15 heures et pour en parler avec nous en
plateau bruno quand celles dont jours
alors vous êtes le responsable
communication à la ferme de gally et à
ma droite jean yves morin dont jours
vous êtes responsable du poulailler de
la ferme et vous êtes venu justement
accompagné de votre mascotte si je puis
dire tout à fait en fait je présente
soubie qui a une des mascottes du
magasin est en fête qui fait partie de
la race des bancs tables de pékin dont
deux poules naines très bien ça valait
bien les à l'ecal parfaite alors ce week
end à la ferme vous recevez la compagnie
des plus mais qui sont ils la compagnie
d une compagnie qui a été créé en 2009
qui regroupe deux acteurs
qui présente des spectacles avec des
poules des petites saynètes avec des
exercices qu'ils vont faire avec des
poules donc il ya des toutes les poules
sont encouragés à travailler avec avec
des petites graines de l'alimentation
pour les récompenser lorsqu'elles font
bien leur numéro donc on va les faire
picorer sur des petites cloches ça va
faire des va faire du bruit
on va là on va les faire circuler leur
faire faire des gymkhanas on va leur
faire tenir en équilibre sur des décors
et des petits spectacles
originaux un peu décalé et on souhaitait
lancer un petit peu la saison des poules
à la ferme de gally en offrant à nos
visiteurs un spectacle qui va se
dérouler à quatre reprises lors de
l'après midi de dimanche ce sont des
extraits du spectacle c'est bien cela
c'est pas le spectacle en entier boxer
c'est quatre extraits qui ont duré une
demi heure et donc ils vont ceux qui
vont se répéter tout au long de tout au
long de l'après-midi et donc les les
spectacles les numéros vont vont
s'enchaîner et veut pas forcément être
répétée tous dans le même ordre et et
dans le même sens lors des quatre
représentations alors pourquoi le faire
venir donc ce week end vous parliez de
lancer la saison c'est à dire oui c'est
à dire que la poule est un animal qui
est reconnue et appréciée notamment
parce qu'elles ont des oeufs ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que
la poule même les poules dit pondeuses
celle qui pondent le plus ne pourront
pas régulièrement tout au long de
l'année elles vont pondre avec le
printemps tout là toute la belle saison
et puis à l'automne le rythme de ponte
va pas diminuer et il va être au plus
bas en hiver et au printemps les poupons
deux se remettent à pousser ça qu'on
joue c'est pour ça qu'on dit que la
saison va va se lancer et on voulait
fêter le printemps fêtait le fait que
les poules se remettre à pondre avec son
exotisme attaque d'accord alors la
compagnie a joué dans de nombreux
festivals dans des théâtres renommée je
sois un produit également sur le plus
grand cabaret du monde présenté par
patrick sébastien donc à la fois du
cirque du théâtre vous l'avais dit je
vous propose justement un petit aperçu
à
alors on le voit un petit peu sur sur
les images les poules paraissent un
petit peu obéir aux artistes est ce
qu'on peut vraiment dresser une poule
alors en fait une poule on va pas
forcément effectivement l'adresser au
sens qu'on peut l'entendre en fait on va
travailler avec la poule ce que la poule
sfr c'est en fait une poule est un
animal qui et qui fait toujours la même
chose et en fait on va les ducs est plus
que de l'adresser et en fait on va les
ducs et ans avec de la friandise en fait
diane dans ses spectacles à des petites
friandises dans les mains et en fait
elle attire la poule pour faire les
spectacles pour faire ce qu'elle demande
à faire la poule avec ses friandises
mais en fait au fur à mesure du temps la
poule va toujours faire la même chose
elle va le répéter sans aucun problème
la friandise alors une friandise en fait
pour une poule ça peut être une petite
graine ça peut être un petit mesli ça
peut être un petit vers de farine une
feuille de salade par exemple dont elles
sont très friandes est en fête qui va
attirer la poule très bien alors à la
ferme de gally aujourd'hui vous élever
des poules dans des fermes ouvertes au
public apparemment donc sur 400 mètres
carrés plus de 40 races de poules c'est
pas mal est-ce que pouvez vous nous dire
un petit peu qu'elle quels sont les gros
type de poules qu'on connaît et parmi
les poules pondeuses et plus d'ornement
qu'on différencie tout à fait en fait il
existe trois grandes familles de poules
différentes on va parler de la poule
pondeuse on va parler de la poule
d'ornement et la poule de chair la poule
pondeuse c'est la poule donc qui va nous
apporter les oeufs et on va classer dans
la famille poupon deux des poules qui
vont pondre en moyenne entre 200 et 250
e à l'année et c'est la poule
traditionnelle en fait qu'on connaît
tous dans la cour de ferme après vous
allez avoir toutes les races d'ornement
toutes les races d'ornement c'est toutes
les races de poules qui sortent un petit
peu de l'ordinaire par leur aspect
physique elles peuvent avoir comme la
hollandaise où la pad ou un chapeau sur
la tête un chapeau de plumes sur la tête
elles sont plus ou moins de grande
taille et en fait elles vont pondre mais
en fonction de la race ça va aller de 50
e par an à 200 250 e à l'année on est
d'accord toutes les poules pondent mais
à des degrés à des degrés différents
d'accord est la ferme de gally vous
vendez aussi des poules mais on vend des
poules donc comme je le disais tout à
l'heure la saison propice pour acheter
des poules arrive maintenant avec le
redémarrage des beaux jours où les
conditions climatiques sont plus adaptés
aux peaux puisque la poule apprécié -
l'humidité donc avec le printemps on
retourne vers les beaux jours donc oui
effectivement on vend plusieurs dizaines
de races de poules d'accord et alors la
mascotte quel type de poules alors la
mascotte qui est bien sage l'a
d'ailleurs fait partie de la race de la
bande am de pékin en fait c'est une race
naine et c'est une race qui est qui
vient de chine à l'origine et en fait
c'était une des deux préférés des
empereurs de chine donc en fait c'est
une race qui est extrêmement ancienne
qui a été développée et c'est une race
qu'on va que je vais
préconisé pour les milieux urbains c'est
une petite poule de petite taille qui
est gentil comme tout qui est adorable
avec les enfants qui s'est très sociable
et en fait ça fait vraiment partie de la
famille et qui se laissent caresser sans
aucun problème d'accord et on remarque
depuis quelques années justement
l'animal refaire un peu son apparition
dans le jardin des des particuliers
apparemment ça de nombreux avantages
tout à fait alors c'est effectivement
serait que la poule en fait on dit
souvent que la poule à désertifier la
campagne est investi la ville et c'est
un petit peu le cas en fait la poule est
un animal déjà qui va nous apporter des
oeufs et autant dire que manger ses
propres the n'a rien à voir avec des
yeux qu'on peut acheter dans le commerce
on utilise aussi beaucoup la poule
contre la réduction des déchets
alimentaires on en parle de plus en plus
c'est quelque chose qui est au goût du
jour et une poule va consommer en
moyenne entre 100 et 150 kg de déchets
végétaux par an donc tout ce qui est des
déchets alimentaires restes de repas
pour les enfants c'est un excédent
helvey parce que c'est vraiment un
animal de compagnie qui est
extraordinaire pour des enfants et un
excédent insecticides naturels une poule
est un animal qui est omnivore et en
fait qui va être capable dans le jardin
de consommer des vers de terre des
limaces des escargots et en fait qui va
éviter l'utilisation de produits
chimiques c'est pas mal déjà ses
avantages merci beaucoup pour pour ces
informations et sachez d'ailleurs que le
poulailler et le reste du magasin est
ouvert du lundi au dimanche c'est bien
ça sans interruption peut tout à fait et
ce dimanche 8 mars donc ne ratez pas les
extraits du spectacle des plumes et
rendez vous dès 15h merci à vous d'être
venu sur notre plateau on passe tout de
suite au rendez vous musicaux du week
end
l'auditorium de l'école de musique de
trappes a servi de studio
d'enregistrement pour trois solistes
dont marianne piketty directrice
artistique des solistes de lavilledieu
plusieurs thèmes de musique se mélangent
dans ce disque catherine mulato et
william l
un son cristallin
pas un souffle une ambiance presque
solennelle nous sommes à l'auditorium de
l'école de musique de trappes pendant
quatre jours marianne piketty au violon
dana ciocarlie au piano magali léger au
chant ont enregistré un cd plus d'une
heure un quart de musique baroque et de
chambres autour d'oeuvres de camille
saint saëns et de sama seuil de la fin
du 19e siècle et début 20e des oeuvres
inédites pour la plupart
c'est parti d'une dune d'une amitié
entre magali dana et moi un désir ou là
toujours toutes les trois envie d'aller
défricher un peu d'aidé d
le père thouars inconnu
m
la musique de chambre c'est une
c'est une école de vie en fait pour bien
faire de la musique de chambre faut
avoir envie de mettre en valeur l'autre
elle tellement aller coûte finalement on
s'oublie complètement et on est au
service de la musique et puis de ce que
peut apporter l'autre et écouter les
choses se font par un respect par rien
n'a encore une fois ben dans la belle
époque tout toute la richesse là le
chatoiement de la musique française du
de la fin du romantisme pour cet
enregistrement les trois solistes
bénéficie de l'appui de la belle de
prestige de distributeurs français
européens et même américains c'est une
première fierté
la seconde c'est aussi d'enregistrer ici
attrape au sein de l'école de musique
laouni rien de piketty et ses amis se
produisent depuis 15 ans pour
transmettre l'amour de la musique
classique à des enfants souvent éloigné
de cet univers ici elles ont trouvé une
ambiance musicale parfaite c'est un
joyau distel la maison de disques y
était
très très très heureuse de l'acoustique
qui pensent que c'est une acoustique
parfaite pour l'enregistrement parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle sec c'est à dire
mais c'est quand même il ya des mâles de
bois et donc c'est une belle acoustique
sèche sans aucun défaut paraît-il
acoustique ce qui est rare de nos jours
ce disque distribué notamment par sony
et harmonia mundi sera disponible à
l'automne
et si vous voulez entendre les
concertistes des solistes de la
villedieu et notamment sa directrice
artistique
rendez vous ce samedi 7 mars à la mairie
de trappes pour un concert événement un
concert où les solistes de la villedieu
et orchestre manifesto vous feront vivre
les plus beaux concertos marianne
piketty nous détaille cet événement le
prochain concert est très important pour
nous et a été source de grande joie pour
moi c'est que on a la chance d'avoir un
partenariat avec la salle de la brise et
donc on fait un
concert avec leurs caisses maillon festo
et son chef mélanie lévy thiébaut donc
un concert avec david guerrier qui est
victoires de la musique qui est une star
qui jouera ce qui est exceptionnel il
joue aussi bien de la trompette que du
corps dont qui jouera du mail le tube de
2 du répertoire de trompette et moi je
jouerai le concerto de mendelssohn ainsi
que des pièces courtes les airs
bohémiens de sarrasin et c'est très
important pour nous parce que la pms q
donc l'association pour la promotion de
la musique à saint quentin en yvelines
le désire vraiment ce qui fait vraiment
vibrer son président hervé charge c'est
d'apporter la musique à tous et on
poursuit cette édition avec
l'association multisons et son premier
tremplin rock
je vous le disais dans les titres ce
dimanche 8 mars à voisins le bretonneux
un tremplin rock et pop rock est
organisée à la salle de la tour julie
fillon nous a rejoint au plateau bonjour
alors vous êtes la responsable
communication à l'association multisons
qui organise cet événement alors le
principe donc six groupes tous
originaires de saint quentin en yvelines
vont se produire sur scène est ce qu'il
faut le dire un petit peu plus oui
chaque groupe aura une vingtaine de
minutes pour proposer des compositions
éventuellement des reprises
et un jury composé donc de trois membres
s'exprimera de façon à noter à ces six
groupes et le public également sera en
mesure de voter
et de déterminer donc qui est le
meilleur en tout cas les trois meilleurs
groupes et quel est l'objectif
finalement de cet événement l'objectif
c'est doit à ses musiciens amateurs dont
20 de faire faire découvrir leurs
compositions
c'est également de les aider à faire des
scènes
voilà peut-être même les rangs
professionnels qui sait on verra dans
les années à venir et puis c'est aussi
de les récompenser avec des glo
intéressant pour des jeunes groupes
d'accord et alors comment la sélection
de ces groupes at elle été faite c'est
un casting à mur ou non il n'y a pas eu
de casting ça fait par bouche à oreille
et puis également par une campagne de
communication sur sur facebook
principalement
des groupes nous ont envoyé des vidéos
et puis selon le niveau souhaité on a
fait un retour favorable et six groupes
ont été retenus très bien et bien je
vous propose d'écouter un medley
justement de quelques groupes qui seront
présents sur cette scène
gagné
c'est
et c'est un
on l'a vu les styles sont plutôt divers
d'eau qui sera composé d'un jury alors
il ya donc comme j'ai tout à l'heure
trois membres un professionnel du monde
de la musique olivier yamaska donkey
également habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux et puis deux
musiciens et passionné de musique en
espèces
vincent pour sac et christophe
boissonnade d'accord et comment on va
surpasser le vote du public quand même
pourra-t-il voter le public le un pub le
public disposera de billes de couleurs
et une couleur associée à un groupe et
voilà pourra mettre 7 bis dans un
récipient d'accord alors pour les
groupes blanc qu il y aura un enjeu il
sont en compétition finalement corps
emporteront les gagnants les gagnants
auront la possibilité de faire une scène
le 5 avril
il y aura également la possibilité
d'avoir un enregistrement
d'un ou deux morceaux en studio dans les
studios de metas hausse à la grange à
son voisin et puis également un coaching
avec olivier daneau ce qu'a très bien
alors on va s'arrêter un instant sur
votre association que multi sont à
l'origine de ce projet alors une
association qui a été créée en 2000 le
11 et qui est installée à
voisins-le-bretonneux quel est son
ambition alors lüthi sont à plusieurs
projets il ya le projet tous en scène le
projet groupe en scène on a également
des projets d'accueil du groupe
partenaire on travaille également sur
les temps d'activités périscolaires
on fait également des master classes
dans diverses spécialités le blues cette
année notre ambition c'est de montrer
que nous sommes un acteur incontournable
de la vie locale
mais également qu'on est là pour aider
les amateurs de musique
à s'exprimer dans leur art d'accord le
bo de beaux projets absolument mais ses
organes en tout cas donc je le rappelle
premier tremplin rock rendez vous ce
dimanche à partir de 14h à la salle de
la tour de voisins-le-bretonneux faut-il
réserver d'ailleurs comment ça se passe
non c'est pas nécessaire de réserver
vous pouvez venir directement sur place
très bien merci beaucoup d'être venus et
ronaldinho on continue en musique
direction le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à présent
iphigénie en tauride de l'oeuvre de
l'allemand glock est présentée à partir
de ce vendredi 6 mars et ce jusqu'à
dimanche une tragédie lyrique ou le
texte et la musique s'imbriquent
totalement catherine vue là tôt et
elodie moines
le ton est dramatique la mise en scène
volontairement sobre les paroles en
français l'oeuvre de gluck du xviiie
siècle détonne avec les variations
lyrique du bel canto du 19e iphigénie en
tauride est présenté au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mise en scène
par jacques osinski nous sommes dans
l'esprit de la tragédie grecque adapté
au chant lyrique c'est comme si c'était
une pièce de théâtre avec musique il n'y
a pas une attente ro chacun aurait
justifié son parent comme au 19ème
siècle à l'opéra des états d'âme avec du
bel canto ou des airs et c'est là c'est
vraiment un rituel comme ça quelque
chose de très épuré très sombre
le texte et la musique très imbriqué
rien ne prend le pas sur l'autre dans
cette histoire une jeune femme est
partagé entre deux âmes
look au moment où il écrit cette
partition est véritablement dans une
dans une réflexion sur les liens qui
peut y avoir entre le texte et la
musique certes mais aussi entre la
tragédie à l'efficacité dramatique la
musique et c'est d'autant plus important
pour lui qu'il entend véritablement
s'opposer à des gens qui n'ont pas
exactement les mêmes convictions cuite
lui-même et en allemand mais défend une
esthétique qui se base sur on va dire à
la fois sur sa rigueur d'allemand et en
même temps sur toute la tradition
française pour chanter les textes
d'iphigénie en tauride les jeunes
solistes de l'atelier lyrique de paris
un vrai challenge pour eux c'est un très
beau texte français c'est parmi les
derniers grands livres est littéraire en
langue française dans notre répertoire
car au 19e siècle après ce sera beaucoup
plus plu
livret d'opéra parce que nous avons un
très beau texte qui est très émouvant
iphigénie en tauride à découvrir au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
6 au 8 mars
et on termine cette édition avec les
sorties ciné de la semaine et les avis
des spectateurs au micro d' elodie
moines les effets spéciaux sont
formidables et puis c'est le genre de
film qu'on peut qu'adorer quoi ça ça
bouge dans tous les sens et c'est bien
fait c'était très bien l'histoire en
général les films les effets spéciaux
schapi
l'histoire enfin il ya un sujet qui est
intéressant c'est le transfert de la
conscience c'est très bien c'est un film
sur la vie quand on dit sur l'
intelligence artificielle et c'est bien
sûr que le film est bien tournée voilà
sauvés très bien car bon film de science
fiction et puis les acteurs sont bons
vont il ya une histoire à une histoire
de deux sentiments
les robots deviennent sentimentaux un
peu on transmet toutes deux tout le
cerveau toute l'âme dans dans un robot
et le coup de coeur de la semaine c'est
celui de gueule pineau du grenier à sel
de trappes bonjour cette semaine je
voudrais vous parler d'un film que l'on
passera samedi soir donc ce soir à
samedi 7 à 20h45 il s'agisse du film th6
clash x 11 38 le premier film de georges
le 15 qui il a tourné en 1971 et qui est
un film qui est devenu un film culte
samedi soir nous présenterons dans le
cadre d'un ciné philo c'est un peu la
première fois qu'on fait ça et ça sera
avec le philosophe et enseignant qui
s'appelle xavier papaïs il est
enseignant à l'école normale supérieure
et philosophe le thème de cette soirée
ciné philo ce sera la déshumanisation la
société de contrôle puisque l'histoire
de thx c'est justement une société hyper
contrôlée ou un homme qui s'appelle thx
11,38 puisque ça se passe au 25 25ème
siècle et que les les hommes et les
femmes sont répertoriés par des noms à
part dénombré des numéros donc ce fameux
thx 11 38 a commis une erreur incroyable
avec une autre femme il a couché avec
elle et c'est interdit voilà donc comme
ça va amener plein de questions ce sera
donc ce samedi 7 à 20h45 vous retrouver
tout ça sur notre site internet www
cinéma le grenier à sel point com merci
à samedi
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis prochain rendez-vous
avec l'actualité dès lundi 18h sur tv
fil 78 d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week end